Well. Well, well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Ah,
I love nails
right away. Okay. All right.
Have you got one for you?
Whoa.
Hm.
Nolan [inaudible] grains or anything?
Love it.
Huh?
Hello?
Okay.
Hey,
there it is. You couldn't roll your
eyes enough during that song. Um,
that was struggles. It's really
funny. Keely. Pretty good, Huh?
I loved it. Yeah, it was really cute.
It was top dog as my dad losing
his mind over some funny jokes.
I like hearing him retell
the Polack jokes. Yeah.
Cory's like they buried their father,
it's c and they drown.
They drown digging the grave
and he loves it. He loves it.
He has a man. He has some of those just
in the chamber. Always ready to go. Yeah.
Yeah.
Well we should ask him the
next time they're going to
come to visit us and a few
months here,
we should ask them to prepare some more.
Maybe he could tell us some yeah, on
the show. Yeah. Bring him in here.
Oh, we just, yeah, we just need to read
some jokes. It'll definitely, yeah,
he'll definitely kill anything,
any street joke.
But especially blonde, blonde
of Polish. She likes, yeah,
dumb lane. Dumb. The dumber,
the better stupid people.
Right. Who wasn't there?
Who was a famous comic. Is that like a no,
that's, you know, you're a redneck one.
Oh, Jeff Foxworthy. Yeah. People
like those lanes. You know,
some of those are really funny. Yeah. Oh
yeah. He gets thrown in that like, oh,
he's a redneck guy,
but like some of those are pretty funny.
I like all three of us or three of them.
Four of them.
They're all have something good,
you know? Yeah. I mean, yeah.
Every comic has something funny
about saying in that lane,
you might be a redneck if some
of them are, you know, he,
he wrote probably a thousand of them. Some
of them are really fucking funny. Yeah.
Yeah. I like that. Ron White though. He's
my fav. Yeah, he's at the store a lot.
I call me tater salad. I like
that too. That impression. Again,
a calm day. You do shit. Why aren't
you doing more impressions? Really?
Well, why don't you do a Ron
White? Did you feel like,
oh well I'll have to get my glass.
My wife has a big girl and then he takes
a drink and they all start laughing.
Yeah. And now we go made up.
Yeah, I think we're good.
Let's move on to something else
completely. That was really good. Oh,
it was really trying. Can
I have a sip your sona? Uh,
I mean I have my beverages lined up if
we could go over them real quick. Yeah.
I have a glass of water and finally
I'm like four episodes. I have a Cvi,
which I'm a big fan of and I have a
coffee. Ice Coffee. I see that I have,
I'm reluctantly drinking.
Is Eva cause you stock the fridge full of,
do you want a sip of this one? Well I just
want yours. Tastes better all the time.
What are you talking about? It's the
same one. Yeah, but I like yours. Yours.
Are you serious right now?
Like was one of that one?
Well I don't like drinking my own.
Can I like to have sips of yours?
That's the whole point. I don't like my
own. Can I like sips of your kidding me,
but I like sips of Georgia. My own
drink. What is that? I don't know.
It's what I like doing.
I don't like drinking a whole can,
but I like to have a few sips of yours.
Maybe a quarter of it. That's yours.
Just backwash. I want to hear
or someone a little sub years.
Are you being serious? Yeah. Me
To open that give you that. Yes,
but then I want you to drink from it too.
I liked that.
We fluid bond in the same cup.
That is weird man.
I like to share at the soda with you.
I don't like to have my own sword.
I don't understand what's going on
cause I like to share. We're married.
Sharing is caring things.
There you go.
See it tastes better when
it comes from someone else.
How angry would your mom get growing
up when you and I wrote him like that
please. And it never did
make me laugh. Of course.
It still makes me laugh. Burps and
farts. High Action makes me laugh.
Her upset makes me
laugh. Right. But for me,
I like your burps the best because I
feel like they always tell a story.
Thank you. The way that you like,
it's nice to be appreciated.
I love the, um, the, the
forcefulness. Think what I like,
what makes me laugh all the time. When
you belt, it's that you're so subdued.
Like you're so chill and then your,
your burps are just violent rips. Yeah.
You're like, ah, but then you always
maintain, you're still composure.
Yeah.
That's the fast part is it?
You don't even let the hype get
to your own head. Thank you. Yeah.
I've always been good at,
you know, being modest. Yeah.
You just kind of let it go. You
just let it roll. Thank you.
And wait for people to acknowledge
how good you are. Thank you.
Speaking my language. I can't wait
for Ellis to start ripping up.
And then he smiled. He's like,
he likes them right now. Yeah.
We got him to go after he drinks.
That's super funny.
That is funny.
He learned that from you.
All right, let's, um, let's pull this
out far. These genes away. Ready?
Yeah, let's do it. Man.
You got three man that weigh
over 200 pounds a piece.
A woman that's a little plump girl and
a daughter who's 13 and you're going to
try to take 12 of trouble sausage and
a couple of dozen eggs and piggy back.
It ain't gonna work.
Don't bring in one loving to then
go to your mom's house.
Christina.
Yeah,
there you go.
I love it. It's just for our people
with it following the audio saga.
Uh, I just hired an audio engineer. Did
they ain't gon fuck such so annoying.
Wow.
Um, wait a minute. Wait, you're
just going to let that roll.
You're not going to compliment me on that.
That was great.
That was a great burger.
First of all,
I held it in for a longer time just
to let it grow and build. Yeah,
I look, I restrained myself and then
I lie that a go. It was really good.
Not really.
Probably that's why about audio.
Oh shoot.
So this is actually the old,
old board.
I have it hooked up through a
direct box in there. Nothing.
I get like minimal sound. So can we
not play? Oh, those are just drops.
We can't play still. Yeah. It's
just, it's super frustrating.
I don't know what else to do. Well that's
why I hired someone and he's coming in.
Yeah. It's maybe by next week
it'll be fixed. Yeah. Maybe.
Maybe speaking of holding in,
so you held it in that burp.
Do you remember what happened last week?
Yeah,
so I wrote it down so we
could discuss it today.
So you made, remember you all of a
sudden you got to kick in the, uh,
we'll,
we'll get to the sausages here anymore.
Of course we're going to get it done.
You got you in the middle of the day.
We were going to have something
for dinner and you're like,
I really want Mexican. Well,
there's a story to that too.
We'll get into that in the moment.
So, but we did it, you know,
somewhat healthy you style
because we didn't meet,
but we did a lettuce wraps
instead of shells. Right.
And then you have some
cheese and whatever. Yeah.
So that's our version, you
know, of Mexican. Anyways.
That meat though has a little bit of, you
know, it's meat. Has some grease to it.
And then we had moms sashes and evening
probably three or four hours after we
ate man.
Like as soon as I laid on that table,
I was like farts right at the door
too. Like they were like, excuse me,
like knocking on the door. And did you
actively clench your cheeks hard? Yeah,
I did.
And you know,
I remember really having to focus and
kind of feeling like you can't really
relax.
And then,
I mean I held them for awhile and
that they were fighting, you know,
they wanted to come out and then probably
about an hour into it I feel like wow,
they're totally gone.
And so,
but that's what happens is
they go up inside of you.
But here's the neat part of the story.
So it was it like, you know, after,
after it was over, everything was fine.
It didn't really have those farts anymore.
Wait,
you're saying so eventually you will,
you clenched you clients to clenched and
the farts went up inside of you and you
were able to relax through the rest
of your massage. But after, I mean,
I guess I cleanse for a while
and then all of a sudden we're back
at, you know, bedtime or laying around.
I have like one little fart and I'm
like, Oh, where, where are the farts?
That's the thing.
I don't know where they are.
And I'm curious because I could feel
that they were really there and you felt
them up inside of you. That's
right. So the next morning, but no,
I didn't really feel that anymore.
I can just go like there.
I don't know where it is. They're just
going. So the next morning though,
I have a early flight so I get up before
you're up. Oh, you are super early.
That day I remember that.
I go down in the kitchen,
I make myself a cup of coffee and I
start ripping like 15 seconds and I heard
them from upstairs.
They were like,
like really,
really good.
The neighbor was starting a motorcycle
or something. It was something
something was going on and I realize
those parts did I held 12 hours earlier or
whatever. We're finally finding their
way out. Wow. Isn't that something?
Wow. What a neat story. Thank you. I mean,
I'm thankful that they came out
in the house and not on the plane.
I just orient the airport or in the car
ride anywhere. They were for a while.
And did they smell worse cause
they had been fermenting in the,
I don't really think so.
They here,
you hear him in the
background a little bit.
It's so faint and I'm so
upset that I can't. Yeah,
you can't really hear him. That's
a problem with the, yeah. Yeah.
That's asked for it. Whereas I recognize
that part anywhere. Yeah, I know it.
Even when it's faint, like the, it's
like the distinct cry of your own baby.
I understand it. King up
was, there's like a son.
He's like a source.
Now it's interesting that you mentioned
the Mexican food because I too,
the reason,
well here's my story leading up to the
Mexican food is that I was making Brown's
every day,
every morning,
but they were small and they weren't
girthy and they weren't really what I'm
accustomed to and so I thought,
you know what I'm going to do?
What I normally do is I kind of
give myself a little diarrhea,
like not a lot, just a little to get
the system going, get the pipes out,
get the pipes cleaned and then move on.
And so what I normally do is I ordered
Thai food and I'll get like a Penang
curry or something and put some extra
Surratt Sri Registry Racha and there.
So I ate the Thai food and then I was
like, this is going to be at next morning.
Here it comes. No browns like
it was just like a normal brown.
So wait how constipated constantly like
I was making the browns but they were
kind of, is it for when they're a
little harder, lower down the scale,
like a six lower down the scale,
like a seven,
a three well three still pretty healthy.
I mean one and two are pretty hard. It
wasn't hard. Just not a lot came out.
Oh well balls,
but not a lot.
Not like pebbles when they're pebbles,
you're just dehydrated.
And I wouldn't even dream of being
dehydrated. It doesn't anymore.
So I got the tie and then I
thought, well, she really,
I got to amp this up to the next day.
I had Korean food that usually does it.
The soondubu soup.
Nothing really.
I'm thinking I got to go
Mexican and that's when we
went to a whole farts and we
got all the stuff for Mexican and
I'll tell you what next morning,
big chocolate city, Brown everywhere.
And I think it's the salsa.
It's actually the salsa that
does it for me every time.
So you didn't have farts during
that mom's size? No. Really? No.
The mid, the next I felt like,
oh, I gotta shit pretty hard.
And I'd also had dino tying
Korean behind the Mexican.
So f a r k still got that one.
That's the best. That lady, she said.
She said if f a R T F A R t. O.
N. A nerd. Remember at the, uh,
at that tells that that national
thing though she was drunk.
She was like fucking yes,
correct. The hypocrite.
A R. T. Yeah. Yeah. Hypocrite. Yeah.
Um, Eh, eh,
that's really funny. Um, well
that was something, I mean,
I'm glad you were able to,
but what we also discovered
something else that we haven't had,
we haven't brought up.
What's that? Oh my God. Revelation. Yeah.
Have, um, we've had this,
your friend brought this to our
sources on the street. Yeah.
So everybody's always like, oh my God,
I'm dreaming of a double five class. Like,
when will it happen? Can I get one?
Does this count? And there's, you know,
I sneezed and I course
like, no, of course not. No.
So a double pipe classic
if you don't know,
is it an expression I
coined a very proud of that.
And it's when somebody burps
and farts at the same time, um,
it is, it's really quite
rare, uh, and, and really, uh,
a moment to celebrate.
And most people go quite some
time without experiencing it.
Sometimes years in between mine. Yeah.
I mean, I've met people, you know,
whenever I meet somebody and they have
the, the elbow classic shirt, I go,
did you earn it?
We'll say, yeah, that's what he will say.
No, I have it. And I go, wow. Leaving,
you know, you know, you know we should
do for those who have had one, yeah,
we should put like a, a gold
metal, like a gold star Gold Star.
And then if you haven't,
you just haven't earned your stripes yet.
You're like really good idea.
Yeah, we have to reproduce it. Oh,
and if you've had multiples,
it'll be like in the military,
like you get your stripes. Yeah. Like
you're a five star general. Yeah. Wow.
Maybe you're, imagine having a
five in a lifetime. Unheard of.
Unheard of. Really crazy. You can't do
that. Well I think I've had three or four.
So stops now you're just exaggerating.
You've been there for a couple.
So.
So anyways,
we're talking to one of your
sources who I think has her first.
She just had her first.
She has her first and she goes,
I think I might know the
secret to it. So we, you know,
we stop what we're doing with that.
Put the baby on the ground. Like what?
And she said he too.
It all might be to be constipated.
Right?
Wow.
Think about that for a moment.
I'm pondering it now for
if you're constipated,
you have that kind of
extra push. Yeah, no,
you have more gas kind
of floating in there. So
are like constantly kind of,
you know,
doing a little extra grunt. Right.
So maybe in the world of it.
So in a, in a, in a way here,
and I'm sorry to tell you this,
we're going to encourage
you to dehydrate yourself.
Go ahead and slow down your consumption.
Yeah.
And see if maybe you can get lucky.
Right?
Apparently dehydration is the key to
a successful double pipe. Classic.
[inaudible] wow. What an
interesting revelation. Neat story.
I know. I feel like we need
an x, a special sound for,
for something like that for,
do you have anything there? Not
much. Yes. A R t. There you go. Yeah.
That's the sound. Oh boy. What is that?
Still have that baby
that was like that little Dominican guy.
Remember?
He looks like a kid. He was a
really fired up. Oh, that's in here.
Can you turn, can you turn that audio
up? That, that sounds low to me.
I am a man Nigga. Oh yeah.
I remember that. Yeah.
Once you put that in order in there.
Yeah. Hmm. That's thanksgiving.
He's telling you there's no more
leftovers. Oh, remember? Yes I do. No,
I'd come here. Let me tickle
you. I don't like that one.
Well, let's go. Let's, let's talk
about this. Yeah, it looks good. Um,
my favorite part about
this is that this is real.
A guy called on the,
like the one 800 number for that.
You know the actor Jeffrey
Dean Morgan Sausages. Yes.
This is his sausage company.
This is Jeffrey Dean Morgan
Sausage. And he has a, you know,
a 800 number where I guess
people can leave a message.
This guy left a long message where he's
really upset if they change the size of
the sausages they sell.
Huh. And is a problem.
I don't know where the people come from.
I don't know. If you test your product,
your quality of your product,
your product, very delicious.
Love your sausage for 30 something here.
But I can't take and feed a family of
five on a little 12 ounce roll of voltage.
I don't mind paying you more money
for your 16 ounce roll of sausage,
but you don't have it anymore.
You've got a 12 ounce roll.
So apparently they changed
size of sounds like it.
It had a 16 going and then they change
the 12 but then they also sell a bigger,
but it's bigger than 16 so he's upset
because they've eliminated the perfect
size for his,
for his needs right now it sounds like.
Why doesn't he just get to hours?
It doesn't want to do that.
He wants to buy a 16 okay,
now he's got to spend more money
for two twelvers Oh, I see, I see.
So you've got three man that
weigh over 200 pounds a piece.
A woman that's a little plump girl and
a daughter who's 13 and you're going to
try to take a 12 pound proba sausage and
a couple of dozen eggs and piggy back.
It ain't gonna work.
Apple
a it. So he's got 24 eggs.
Why not do 24 rounds? Is it,
how many people are we talking about
here now, right it the 13 year olds,
three grown men, fat wife. You say three
grown men? I think you said three minutes
and you got three man that way.
So three guys that are 200 pounds.
Oh, losers are living with him.
The big lady and the girl. That's
five people. Five people have 24 eggs.
That's insane. Tour. How many
in between? Let's do the math.
524 that's like four and
a half each of eggs a day.
No, this is a meal we're talking
about, right? Right. So five people.
Five people each have three
eggs. It's 15 right? So He's,
but he's feeding them almost five eggs
per customer. This is a lot bananas. Yeah,
we don't even go through that much. Jesus.
Why would we go? What do you mean what?
We don't eat well because I do the grocery
shopping and we go through a ton of
eggs and a ton of bacon. I know, but
it's no baby jeans. You and myself.
And this is more people and
these are more fat people.
And as far as your 16 ounce and
label and Phage, I don't eat that.
I'm not fuck that man.
No north
sausage bothering people to eat with
the breakfast with the fried egg and a t
bone steak.
Oh,
okay. I didn't know that it was specific
to an area. Well that, what'd he say?
Maple and sage. That I,
that's in the north. Hi Nina.
Her mind I gotta tell you I don't
want that either. Fuck that shit too.
Cause I don't like that sage.
That's the thing.
I don't like an American
breakfast sausage. I hate
it. All the herbs and like,
I don't like it. Don't
like it. I like it either.
Playing like what this guy
is talking about, dude. Yeah.
I like a like a fancy one.
Yeah. You know, he's got a good one. Is
Ralph's good sausage, breakfast sausage.
They have it.
It's the kind that they make there.
I got it for you a while
back and I really liked it.
I'm going to try Jeffrey Dean Morgan
Sausage soon. Yeah. I want to try it
and I think the want to a
little 12 ounce package,
the feet or five people and I'm not going
to buy two of those 12 and where you
go because you won't bounce out
and charges thing and got damn pri.
He's real upset. Well look, if you
love your Jeffrey Dean sausages,
Morgan Jeopardy, Morgan sauces so much,
then pay the extra few bucks. Right? Yeah,
I agree. If you're hooked on the
flavors, you've got to evolve, dude,
but what is sure like you to go back
to your 16 ounce package on your record
often cause I'm not going
to buy it otherwise. Yeah.
I'll just have my own damn fault mate.
Like I used to years ago.
It's not tasty as yours yet,
but it'll work.
Okay. Yeah, man, it's quite a threat.
Do you think the people at Jeffrey
Dean Morgan Morgan were like,
we got to go back to doing
it because it is fun. Maybe.
Maybe they heard this one
message and they're like,
all right, I've got to be it.
I always wonder that when people
are leaving a message like that,
can you think they're going to say,
oh,
fucking Roger said the change our size.
Well,
if enough Rogers I guess leave
messages. Yeah, that's true. Critical,
critical mass.
No, no. 12 map. Goddamn roller.
Call your brother and me and
you kind of found the man.
At least you get my point,
right.
I put it in that fucking pussy
role with ball throwing up a bitch.
Somebody need their ass kicked by Middle
Consumer Geek. Lord. Fuck this shit up.
Whoa. I like that. He
actually thought it was,
yeah, it was a good thing. Yeah. And then
he lost it at the end. Cause I like the,
the severity of it for him.
Like it was a real problem with this
guy had to take to the phone line.
Hold on. What's up? Hold on.
All right, we're back. Um,
no. I know the severity
of, of making that call,
it really bothers him so much that
he has to find the number and call.
I don't think I've ever done that
for like a product I really enjoyed.
I just take it. I'm like, oh, they changed
it. Oh well I guess they changed it.
People Change. People
Change. April changes, little
changes all the time. Yeah.
Right. When did you just kind of
roll with the change? Of course.
I don't know if I'd take to the phones.
Oh my Lord. How about wait, what does he,
he ends on this.
Let's see if we can get even more mad.
Z money. Save money. Save money.
Fuck, I'm gonna eat. Got Dennis.
Wow. Fuck. I'm gonna eat God damn it.
See how it is interesting.
Don't you think that when you do,
when your message changes to that,
then they just probably
disregard your message? Well,
probably listening to his message.
Right? And he's like fucking pussies.
There you go. Then you lose credibility.
I think so.
Now what I've learned about white people
complaining what you do when you're
like,
it's spas are a nice hotels and you've
taught me this cause I used to go the
angry route and sometimes it does work.
Yeah,
but you've taught me that the
wider you go, the way you complain,
the more respect you get.
Well, here's what it's
about. I learned this too,
and I learned this from
doing it the other way.
You basically have to complain to the
people you're complaining about in the way
that they respond to Barry Go. So if
you're in a high end place, right,
you have to complain the way a high end,
like the way they would respond to them,
which means you have to keep your
composure. You can't curse, can't,
you can't get all ad,
they're not going to respond.
What they respond to in like a nice
hotel or a nice restaurant is if you
complain about you,
you tell them,
I'm really disappointed in
my experience and here's why.
And you lay it out for them, then they,
that's the language of that world. Yeah.
So they reply, they can understand
that if you're, I dunno,
maybe on a shooting range
and fucking Arkansas, right.
I Dunno if doing that that way would
maybe there you got to be like,
I just fucking bullshit
man. And then, yeah. And
that's, that makes sense. Yeah.
But the people at Jeff Jeffrey,
Dean Morgan,
I don't know if they'd respond
to that. Yeah, I dunno. I Dunno.
That's a good, that's a good question.
But it is like people respond to their,
their language.
Yeah, that's true. Sometimes
they don't respond to enough.
Like I remember at the time we were
in Dr and the, I forget what they,
what did they done all, we went on some
thing and they promised it was going to
be great and it was terrible.
Yeah.
I feel like we had been robbed of a day
of our vacation cause they are like take
this tour and they ended up throwing
us on a bus. It was horrible. It was,
the whole thing was disappointed.
And I told the guy, I like, hey man,
you stole a day of our vacation.
Like you're,
you're supposed to vouch for this thing
being a good thing. And it was not,
and he was starting to blow me off. Okay,
well too bad. And I was like, no, no, no,
not too bad. You fucked up my vacation.
Yeah. And I used fucking everything.
And then we got some free massage and
that was the time that I worked together.
A lot of line. That's what Dominican's
respond to. You spoke their language.
There you go.
And that's the same place that they had
porno in every room on channel six, nine
hardcore pornography.
That place.
Yeah, but not, sorry, not every room
had it cause the dad boners the pool.
I saw it for a second. It was like
kind of came in and out and I was like,
we have it all the time.
He was like, what we did.
It was so ridiculous. It's crazy. Ooh,
Ooh. Speaking of, um, just went out.
You said complaints or how white people
complain you yesterday where the Oscars
the ultimate grant and last year,
you know,
Oscar's so white was trending.
It was a big thing about not having
people of color nominated. Oh yeah.
I remember this year, uh, not
only were there black winners,
a black bummer won best picture.
That's usually a white category.
Bummer of the year. And this
year was a black bummer. Well,
all black cast to be able to be fair.
Well,
no, no. Now it's different.
They did a team votes,
but I'm saying that it used to be not
only obviously what white people mostly
nominated,
all the academy members were mostly older.
And so now we switched out the academy
members of the academy. People of color.
Yeah.
So it's,
it's more diverse and a black
bummer is a rare category.
Won Best Picture. Moonlight. We have
it. By the way. We should watch.
I won't watch it. I want to see
it. Not because it's a bummer.
I can't,
I don't want to see over white bummers.
I'd like to see that black
men were like this. I don't,
that guy's a really good actor too. I
like if he's on, he's on a house of farts.
He won
best actor.
He's got a
gay black came in. Like what it's
like to, this is what I've heard.
A gay black in inner city, Miami. Slu.
Or it's like in a place where like
that shit's not celebrate it like the,
you know,
the struggle of that.
Okay. What era? Eighties you say? No,
I didn't say era. Um, I don't know.
I think it's contemporary. Yeah,
no. Yeah, I think so. Well,
Miami, you're saying, yeah,
it takes place in Miami.
No,
you were saying that in Miami they teach
them how to give blow jobs. I'm sorry,
I didn't, where'd she saying this?
That The may have sex much earlier.
They do the Puerto Rican.
Yes.
Well just the children,
but no, I have, you know,
I grew up a couple of hours. I say this
people lot of times or like you said,
you grew up in like all these
places. Yeah, I grew up in
a bunch of places. Yeah,
you moved around a lot.
When I,
I lived for a few years at most of what
my high school years were in a few hours
north of Miami and I've,
you know,
some friends from down there and lived
down there and they said they were overly
sexualized at a much younger age
because culturally it was just more,
hey mommy.
Yeah,
it's a super Latin hypersexual
hypersexual culture.
It is hypersexual. Yeah. I mean I remember
the Latin influenced, to be honest.
That's Latin. Well that's Puerto Rico.
I'll tell you why. Not just, well,
some of it because when I went, we went
to Puerto Rico member. We were, yeah,
we just wanted to cruise the manikins
by the way, are way more sway.
Way over sexy. Yes. But
in Puerto Rico I was like,
remember we docked and I was like,
I'm finally here. It's my motherland.
And I was so excited to finally,
yes, soak in my culture.
My people and I,
we went to like just the souvenir shops
right off the boat. Docking area. Yeah.
And every towel was like
naked chick naked guy.
Guy Handshake on top of each other.
Like super sexual culture.
Hypersexual
yeah.
I'll tell you this in a,
I talked to a former pro baseball player
and he said this is an open secret
baseball. Baseball has a huge
Latin professor. Dominican's right.
Has a huge Latin population.
Okay.
The Dominican's specifically
within major league baseball,
like the pro baseball league
in America. Yeah. They,
he said 99% of the time shower separately
from the rest of the players and it's,
it is a regular practice.
It is known amongst major league
players that you don't shower with the
Dominican,
the Dominican shower by themselves.
And the reason is because they
get overtly sexual to the point.
But like it's cool to like each other
but like Dick's lat but Dick's labs where
they think it's normal,
nobody else does.
And my knee slapping their dicks against
each other's ass and he said it's 100%
uh,
accepted thing and they know
that those guys aren't gay,
but nobody else is cool with their
shower behavior. So they let them,
they said that he said
like they all shower set.
This is like a guy who went into detail
about it. Yeah. And uh, you know,
I don't want to say his name,
but he, me, he was in the,
in the League for 10 seasons or you know,
and he played on a few different teams.
Is that every team the same way? The are
showering everybody else showers. Hey.
Yeah.
So at least they know what they like, you
know, resection come all over my face.
That is so funny. Yeah. So we
are, so my point being though,
if Miami is so open sexually,
I'm wondering why this boy,
the story of,
well, the story
specifically, kind of like,
I believe it's like a of
maybe like liberty city
really intersect like hardcore
Gotcha. Black, right, right,
right. Where you know,
it's a homophobic, yeah. More homophobic,
less accepted that to be like a
young gay black guy. So I mean,
but look, it just won best
picture, best supporting actor,
best original screenplay or
best adapted black bomber.
Best Black Bummer of the year.
I am glad that La la land didn't,
it did not win just because, well,
I hate musicals. I know. I
fucking hate him. And My, I was,
I wanted to see that movie and
12 seconds of the movie, right?
The plane yesterday, right?
Oh, you did. And it opens,
uh, at a traffic jam and a car
is like on, um, what's it called?
One of those, you know, where they
a moving shot where it's like,
it's going past all the cars and it stops
at this one car with his girl, like, ah,
over it,
uh, traffic, uh, La Orange.
The Cameron, she's like,
there is something happening now.
And she gets out of the car and
a musical starts and I go exit.
That's how much I want and I won't
watch it. I have no interest. Yeah.
Now here's the thing. You know how much I
love my Ryan Gosling? Yeah, he's in that.
I love him. And I love Emma. What's
her tits at? What's her name?
Emma Watson. Emma. Emma, Emma,
whatever. I really like her. She won.
Oh she did? She won. She's fantastic.
And I like the two of them together
and I won't go see the movie because I,
the the people singing a dialogue
to me it is not appealing.
I fuck it. It makes me crazy
to watch musicals. Yeah.
The only music movie I like is the
muppets. The muppet movie. Yeah.
The Rainbow Connection Song. You
know, that's cause it's the muppets.
I have no tolerance. Um,
can I so fucking boring.
I liked cats growing up. My mom took me to
see cats. Did you ever see that one? No.
Well that's cause they're all
in cat outfits and they're
pretending and cat. Oh,
it's fucking boring too. God
term it. That is boring. I don't,
I'm just not into them. I'm not,
I'm not cultured that way either.
My parents forced me to a lot.
Yeah. Like Swan, Swan Lake.
That's fucking boring too.
I don't want to see any of them right now,
but we have to pretend
that we're cultured people.
We have to take our son to
pretend like where culture.
Don't wait. No, no, no, no, no,
no. My parents did. No, no,
no, no. There Europeans.
I had to like learn all hold was like,
do you really want to go
kind of furrow brow?
You sure you want to go to that?
You want to go to a Laker game?
Maybe it was more fun.
We got to teach him that this stuff
exists. Right. I mean well your job. Yeah,
but I'll be like, I'll put a DVD or you'd
be like, doesn't that look terrible?
I'll try to encourage that
thought, you know? Um,
cause it is hard for a kid to watch that.
My parents used to take me
and I was so bored. Oh yeah.
He went every year to see the nutcracker
and I fucking hated it. I don't want,
I still don't want to sit through it and
I don't want, to me, it's fucking boring.
I'm not a ballet fan.
I want to do this before I forget.
I have some added dates,
June. So let me pull this up.
Back. Hurts really
doesn't feel good.
I have some big added shows coming up,
so I figured I would let you know.
I'm going to,
next week I'm going to, uh, Bethlehem,
the sands casino, Bethlehem,
pa on Israel and Israel and then
Fox Woods on the 10th Comedy Club,
restaurant and casino.
Um, Foxwoods comedy club,
resort and Casino. But I
met the Fox was theater, um,
one show one night, then Boston
for three nights, or excuse me,
three shows the following week.
Greenbay Royal Oak and Chicago.
That's the big add on for me right now
is that I added chicargo March 19th.
If you live there, you have I guess around
three weeks, uh, to get those tickets.
But that show is moving. That's the only
added show for that. Washington, D C.
Uh, I sold out seven shows,
so I added an eighth.
So that eighth show was on the
26. Pittsburgh, Pittsburgh,
Pennsylvania.
I added a 10:00 PM show on April six.
The other one is gone.
Burlington, Vermont.
I added the early show April 8th,
um,
Seattle meet rattle Washington.
I added a late show on Friday
the 14th that is on sale.
Dallas, Texas. Sold
out the house of Blues.
So I'm adding the House of Blues in
Dallas tickets go on sale this Friday.
That'll be the late show
in Dallas for 20 bro.
Super High, super high. And then I
added two more shows. May 12th, Eugene,
Oregon,
go ducks.
I'm going to do a show at the Mcdonald
Theater and then May 13th if you're in
Portland and you didn't get your tickets
back when I announced those April shows,
this is an added show for Portland,
Oregon,
so I'm excited about all those.
They're all at Thomson [inaudible] dot
com check them out when you get a chance.
Jean poor claimed Portland April 13th
through 15th. I'm at the Brayer Improv
down here and a brick California.
Very exciting. April 28th through
29th Sacramento at the punchline.
May 4th through fifth. Phoenix,
Arizona at standup live.
May 19th and 20th June dork titties.
Gotham comedy club.
I'm excited for that one. I'm
never done. New York City proper.
Ever lands on Brooklyn? Never done
it. No. Gotham is really nice. I know.
I can't wait club though. I've only done
suck my juice. I've done like, you know,
everywhere else.
But New York City,
June 1st through third Denver at
the Denver comedy works downtown.
I'm excited about that. Which
you've never done that. Yep.
June 16th and 17th man friend Desco
at the punchline comedy. But no,
it's going to be off the chain.
And my birthday is June 18th. Yup.
So who gives a shit? Can you
plug this in? It's fucking dying.
My batteries messed up on my iPhone.
It keeps the, the charge doesn't keep,
oh, listen to that to deep, Bro. Uh,
last week I interviewed an
actual nonbinary person. They,
they called in, it's their
name was Freddy. Yeah.
And we talked about that. It's
super cool. It's a fun show.
I did actually. Yeah, I did.
I did something right now.
Oh fuck.
It's hard to be fresh if you don't
have money or I can still pull it off.
You don't got no salads.
You Laos,
that's what's up. You understand that
you don't got no sauce, then you're lost.
But you also get lost in the
sauce. You can get, well,
how you get lost in the sauce bitch,
bitch you to get lost in the south.
I know you said,
man,
I don't,
I lost it
most breaking this out. Drop
it sounds right. Right, right.
Oh, but those, the sauce.
Okay.
No meat. Just so when you're born,
can you be born with sauce or do you
okay.
It's sauce.
You get the sauce season
out of the south quad is though.
So you know what's going on there.
No,
but I think it's my favorite conversation
I've ever heard. Pretty Great.
I love that guy so much. Who He is? No,
you don't know who that is. No clue.
But I like him a lot. His Gucci Mane.
Gucci Mane. Now that's before he, uh,
he lost a bunch of weight. I don't know
if you saw that. No, I didn't. Yeah,
that's an old clip. He's, um, he looks
way different now. You will see. Yeah,
I like to see, okay. The Gucci
Mane. When does he sing? I guy.
Was he saying he sings? Um,
God bless America and uh,
but what's the song I would know because
I know you like Gucci Mane. 100%.
How dare you? I'm very
cool. I'm a Midwestern mom.
Let me show you. Moms
know everything. Cool.
So this is him right now.
Right here. Oh, he looks great.
Yeah. Okay. He's such good teeth. Yeah.
Damn. Look at those teeth are perfect.
He lost a bunch of weight. He's great. No
prison. I went to a program that'll
do it, but he's actually in the end.
He got, he got like off
the lane. Yeah. He, um,
so this is kind of like when
that video was, you know,
he's definitely chubbier he's got us,
he put too much sauce on stuff.
That's a problem. Yeah. And
then there's weight loss.
Yeah. Here's free prison. Okay.
So yeah,
he's a little filled out.
His face filled that filled out
and then out of prison. Wow.
Lots of prison diet. It looks good son. It
looks good. It looks good. This is good.
He looks great. Yeah. Yeah. Fucking
trap God doing this thing. Yeah.
I mean you could see like damn dude,
you got to go to prison.
I don't know if you have to, but yeah,
it definitely worked for him. His um,
Dan, he's definitely got it for
him. I liked the sauce. Yeah.
I wish I could, I'd have to listen
to that and really break it down to,
well that's what we do on premise.
And then in philosophy you have your
premise and then you're a and B's prep,
prep, prep positions, propositions.
So this is him syllogism Graham.
See, right. Always looks
good. Like he likes his,
uh, he likes his clothes. This
is lady. They're getting married.
No Shit. She stuck with them
when they, when he was in
prison. That's a real bitch.
There you go. I think that's what he
would say to. Yeah. Oh, she's cute. Yeah,
they look good. They look good together.
Yeah. What do you know her name? Uh,
I forgot it. I don't remember.
Yeah, I don't remember her
name. But I like it. Dude.
I like this guy. You like
Gucci? Ah, he loves the falcons.
I liked that she was ride or die like
that. Him and his girl. What's his name?
Kesha. Okay. Yeah.
Yeah. And they look cute. Yeah, they're
good couple. They are men. They remind me.
A lot of us now I'm not going to find
out that he like beats her song. Right?
I don't know that shit. What
was he in jail for? Oh No,
it was like weapons. Drugs. Yeah. Okay.
As long as it handle like
parole violations. Yeah. Yeah.
Well, yeah. So please, God dammit.
Just to have some flat. Now
let me have yours. I like yours
because yours tastes better.
It's Felicia. You understand what kind
of, what's going on there? It's sauce,
mean coolness.
Well,
I think you know better way to say it
would probably be the confidence spice,
right? Right. Confidence. Like he's
like, you're not born with that shit.
Like life has to season you a
little bit. Yeah, I agree with that.
Yeah.
Some kids are balling your quotes,
so how you can be born with seasoning.
It definitely saved.
No me just hours before
with sauce or do you
look so different now?
Now that you pointed that out?
I would not recognize that dude, if you
show me that picture before. No, no, no.
It looks so much better now. Way
Better. He's also like, like I said,
he's kind of off of like
every night smoking blunts,
drinking because his face is puffy from
all that I was getting fucked up and
it's probably not sleep well. Yeah.
I think he lost like 60 or
80 pounds, dude. Damn. Okay.
Now do you think black people
go nuts for black bomber movies?
White people that go nuts for all bummer
movies. Oh, that's interesting question.
Yeah. I really wonder is that
a good deal too? Who's the,
who's the audience besides white
people that really dig bummer?
I guess all people love a good
bummer, you know, to a degree. I mean,
I think that crosses all,
all races.
Not like to be bummed out at the movies.
Some people,
I mean that's just the type of person.
Regardless. You're right in that it's,
I feel like you do see a lot of
white people celebrating the bumper.
Generally the industry made
of white people who love
to applaud the bummer movie
as opposed to the like the Rob Reiner
film. Yeah. You know what I'm saying?
Or I'm upset.
I get bummed out that we don't see a
comedy celebrated amongst ever best
screenplay. I mean a few, I guess I've
been screenplays, but best picture,
best actors, they never give them to a
comedic performances. And the part that,
that upsets me the most about that,
and I know it's been said before,
but it's very true,
is that a lot of times these iconic
comedic performances can only be done by
that one person.
Whereas the dramatic role,
there's like 10 guys that
could play that role.
There's 10 girls that could play that,
that dramatic role.
But how many people can play
Eddie Murphy in fucking movie?
Uh, what, what is it where
he plays all the characters,
but no one else can do that. Why
isn't that celebrated? Huge talent,
Jim Carrey in basically anything.
It's just nowhere else could do that.
Pet detective is one of the funniest
fucking movies. I loved that movie.
It is one of the only one of the funniest
movies and no one else could play that
role, but it could come close. Yeah,
and if you were to suggest that he get an
award for that, it wouldn't be like, oh,
you're fucking,
if you put him in a movie where he
has cancer and dies and he said, oh,
let's give it up fucking award.
Like the gave,
they nominated Bill Murray
for lost in translation,
which is a great movie and a great role,
but I think you could
nominate him for 10 other roles.
I think it comes down to the people
don't have respect for comics,
the whole thing and they don't realize
like ups are like the clowns of the
entertainment where the dog should
have of the entertainment world,
but we're also then fucking
marine corps of entertainment.
We're fucking writing it
hardcore traveling alone. Yes.
Motherfuckers soon as you see like
an Improv show or a play please.
Or even like acts where
there's two people on stage,
you have somebody else about
like you're not up there alone.
When you're alone, it's a totally
different thing. A guitar. Yeah.
Now they're like praying. It's something
that you can kind of put off. Oh yeah.
All of what's going on on. It's like it's
all of a sudden you have support, right.
I have this thing that
can play as you're doing.
It's not that it's not a skill
or a talent because it is,
but when you're alone with a microphone,
it's way more.
You're way more vulnerable. You're
way more vulnerable. It's all on you.
You can't blame anybody.
Yeah.
It is the fucking Marine
Corps of of entertainment
and we don't get the respect.
And by the way, a comedy actor can do
a serious role, but not vice versa.
Not necessarily.
It's very hard for us
serious actor to do comedy.
Now there's like your
deniros who can get away.
I think de Niro's funny is any like in
meet the Fockers and the parents and the,
I mean,
I think part of that is it,
that material is really
good at that particular one.
I don't think he's actually a funny guy.
I think he's a good actor. Yeah. Yeah,
you're right. You're right.
Maybe he's not so funny.
I'm trying to think of WHO's like
bright who can do both. I mean,
I know, I know Jim Carrey did man on
the moon. Remember when he can do both?
He did. Kaufman? Yeah. Robin Williams.
Mays. Yes. He was great at doing both,
actually. Dramatic actor. Eddie Murphy
is actually really, really good. He,
I think he did get nominated when
he played that dramatic role in the,
what was the,
it was like about Mo town or something.
He played a part in that
that got nominated for
something so fucking talented
date Kilis music and shit. You know,
he made his money and he had a family
last year,
but it was a more serious drama.
He's fucking talent. That guy,
God dammit. Yeah. Like Jamie Foxx.
He won an Oscar for playing
a serious role though.
Only serious give it to you for
comedic role, which is so silly.
I don't understand this.
Yeah, I'm surprised.
You know what white bomber didn't make
it did. Maybe it did. I just don't,
I didn't pay attention was the
one that we saw the arrival,
the one in the future and the alien
thing I got nominated. Oh yeah.
How's it going? One? Yeah.
Let's see. That was a good one.
Yeah. That's not what not a dis
drops tomorrow, right? Yeah.
What are you talking about? When does
this episode drought? Next week? No,
tomorrow night. Oh, so we can
still talk about Oscar Shit. We've,
we've been talking about Oscars.
Do we keep talking about it or are people
going to be sick of this by the time
this drops? That's what I'm
thinking. But I mean, we've, we're,
we're already into it.
Okay. Right? Yeah, I know.
Gosh. It just awesome.
How am I hateful? I just
what, what, what are you talking? Yeah,
we're going out for a romantic getaway
tomorrow night. Uh, arrival was nominated.
Oh, that's good. Yeah. Not bummer. He
enough though? Yeah. They had death in it,
but not enough. It was her
cancer, um, that she, oh,
but she didn't get it. She didn't get
a nomination for that role though,
for a rival. Okay. Okay. Yeah.
Yeah. And that girl's name
is Emma Stone. Emma Stone.
Yeah. She's great. I liked her on
sesame street too. She did balance.
That was her thing was cute.
That's the letter of the day.
It's a letter.
It's a letter is the letter of the day.
Hello?
She means new album.
I would love if he did sesame street.
He probably will. I can't
wait. You probably will. Yeah.
I wish they would have us on sesame
street. That would be like the dream.
They're like now from your mom's house,
podcasts,
everybody pull your
jeans up and then we met.
We liked Grover's fart
and then that's our scene.
You think it'd be a fun thing
to do? F is her fart. Yeah.
They totally would let us.
I don't think they would.
Maybe we put the call out there.
There's a fan that works on sesame street.
Let us know. I would love to do
sesame street. Are you kidding?
I don't give a fuck about anything,
but I would love to do sesame street.
Sesame Street would be amazing cause shit
probably have a little bit of a window
where it could happen in where like your
son can still see it. Ah, it's so cool.
Could you imagine your five years wash?
Oh,
it's easy. You like, hey
guys. Yeah, that's right.
The word of the day. Yeah. Wanting
to the word of the day. Yeah.
I want to the word of the
day. I like it all. I love.
I want to count something with account.
Have you rad?
Because we're talking about today. Have
account is like, Oh gee, sesame street.
Yeah. I love the count. I
love snuffle up a guess.
Um Oh. But Oscar the grouch by far is
the funniest character on sesame street.
He should so funny. He tells kids to
Scram all the time. It's the best. Great.
Now scram scram. So funny. That's great.
And he's always making people miserable.
Yeah. Sorry, we're having too much fun.
Is too high.
Porosity of about 40 to 45% as a
response to the high water content of the
shales from here to here,
the neutron curve falls back
to about 30 ferocity units.
While the density curve remains at about
16% indicating relatively less shale,
there's owners interpreted it to
be a silky shale, possibly align.
Aisha says really boring.
The same body is indicated at
a depth of 12000% even a human.
The look at in the gamma ray
reading shit, Kamara. Yes,
that's a no,
it's bad.
There's not even a person put interval
of porosity is shown at the top where the
porosity curbs average about 23% for us.
What it felt like by the way,
for being just below roll marathon bed.
Yeah.
I mean several groups exhibit a marked
reversal and I see these people follow
this right now that's a
following or chemistry.
I took chemistry for like
a week in high school.
This is what chemistry sounded like to me.
Yeah,
I you understand any of that
show? It's so bad. God Damn. Hey,
Sagar wrote in about sink holes
where you read it. Yeah. Did you,
I texted it to you. It's on your phone.
My phone's dead. Um, sinkholes is a,
it's a real deal, dude. We
got into it last week and, um,
Holy Shit. You know what, just came
out over the news right now. Hmm?
That Elan Musk? Yeah.
Space x Tesla CEO. Yeah.
You're going to send to tourists
to the moon next year. Wow.
Oh yeah. Cool. I definitely would
not want that first ride. Would you
fuck that? Fuck No. But, um, I think
it would be fun to hear the, um, the,
the moon landing deniers.
Crazy ladder as people start talking more.
Yeah.
So that's a letter of the British guy.
So Adam wrote in hygiene
on the topic of sinkholes.
My house is half a mile from one
here in Michigan at swallowed up,
it opened up last month
and swallowed a house.
Repairs will take two years with
the major road closed and the entire
neighborhood smells like sewage every day.
Air Day. Yeah. Every day I'm
hustling. Horrible, horrible,
horrible. Has Real people. Yeah. And
there's nothing. You can do nothing.
And it comes out of the blue.
It's not like there's an alarm,
you can't call the uh, the city and
be like, I demand the earth opened up.
Do we have, um, insurance for that?
Like, is that part of your house?
Insurance is sinkhole insurance?
Good question.
But I want to put that one in here.
That one out. Yeah. Now, let's see here.
What did we not cover? Constipation
equals farts equals double pipe. Classic.
You're fart story.
Let's see.
I tried giving myself diarrhea
check. Oh, I didn't also,
I've got a story. Go ahead. Well,
this weekend I should say I was in
Canadia and I had a great time. Um,
I was in Edmonton, Calgary, Vancouver,
and in Calgary I hung
out with your old buddy
from road rules,
Shane Jane,
his lovely wife, Christie. And um,
there a sister in law and I had a
great time there. And then Vancouver,
Vancouver was bananas, um, at
the, at the vogue. And you know,
one of the things it was,
it was so cool. It was like,
there's all the over a
thousand people there and,
and then they're coming up to me and
they're telling me how much fun they have.
But they're also saying that like
they watched a, they're like,
I'm watching the lighting guy,
the sound guy,
and seeing like how everybody kind of
works together and they're other tweeting
me that they are enjoying that. And I
was like, ah. They're like, you know,
those are as much of a
part of the show is Tom. Yeah.
Like even Tom, he's out there,
but he's just one element of what's going
on. It's such a, it's such a cool thing,
you know, that like everybody
was just like, ah, man,
this whole shows such an awesome,
neat thing and I just love, you know,
it was just love all the components
because really those guys are just as
important as time, if not
more. And without those guys,
there's no you, you know?
Yeah. And I'm just so thankful for the
lighting guys and those great, you know,
they're the real stars Tom, not you.
Even the guys that load in, you know,
they're just so important.
Yeah.
The guys a clean up after and even
like when I get off and they don't say
anything to me about the
show, I still go, wow,
you're so cool and important. Can I tell
you what that is? I feel like Garth,
that whole thing of like they're just
as there are the stars too. Like no,
they're not. No, they're not.
And here's why I'm not saying
that they're not important.
Not Everybody wants to be at the front
of the line or in front of the audience.
Some people enjoy being behind
the scenes and that's okay.
And that's what they want.
They assume people assume that,
that that guy looked at assumes
everyone wants to be out. Right.
He's assuming that he is better than
them and he's trying to elevate them so
that he doesn't look like a
Turd, but it's like, dude,
maybe they want to be behind
maybe the fucking phony.
Maybe the lighting guy doesn't
want people watching him. Yeah.
If you thought of that,
like that's probably,
and of course they know they're
good at their job. I was doing it.
I was in Edmonton as the same time
as him. Oh my God. Did you know it?
I was done.
I sent him a tweet.
Um,
he did nine Rogers arena show bananas.
So he sold bananas hundred
and 80,000 tickets.
So you know how crazy that was to them.
So you know,
if you go to like for
instance, staple center, uh,
and you look on the ceiling,
they have banners of championships.
So it'll say that, you know, the 2002
Lakers, NBA world champions. Right.
So in, in Edmonton, at Rogers
arena, they have Oilers,
you know, Yemen snorers my dad liked
them. So I remember what hockey has,
championship banners. Right.
They added while he was there,
a Garth Brooks banner that says nine
sold out shows bananas with G J circle.
Yeah.
G and t G. Yeah. You know
what, and it happened while I
was there. I feel like that,
you know, well, you, you and I are the
Garth and Trisha of podcasting, TNC,
the comedy world, the TNC.
TNC. Yeah. Love Tea, love,
see love g and t and now it's
Tennessee. Welcome to a studio G. Yeah.
Happen pretty goes happy birthday
to g two G two g his alter ego.
Yeah, Trish. Really? I think he starts,
he should start paying attention to Trish.
Oh, packed on the pounds and a really
short time. Oh well no, not that we did.
We all don't at some time, but I
think she, it happened fairly quickly.
So I'm wondering if Tricia's okay, maybe
she's depressed or sick or like what's,
what's going on?
I need some answers and if you guys could
ask him on the next studio jeans, Hey,
what's up with her weight gain?
Why is Trish so fat guys?
What's going on? And she's a pretty
looking girl. She's pretty, pretty wise.
Trousseau fat was just fat.
How can Chris looks like
bird phrase it that way.
Portray she is a very beautiful woman.
I just don't know what's going
on with her when, when I um,
I just want to thank the
grips and the lighting crabby.
Bert,
Bert.
Gee,
I'm going to start doing that now.
A lot of people tweeted me his
alter ego when he did that and I,
and we've already covered that on your
show. Them. Chris Gaines, it says, yeah,
see that's the mental
illness I'm talking about.
That's the neat,
but that, that's what I'm talking
about. That, that weird, you know,
maybe you know what,
maybe it's just the pressure
of the country audience
that you have to be down to
earth and real.
I am,
because I learned this
listening to country music.
People talk about it before,
like, I forget where it was from,
but Dolly Parton's is kind like she'll
let people sleep in her backyard and
stuff just so that she's not
seen as as me. That's a big deal.
And that and the country community, if
you're seen as uppity or mean or snobby,
forget it.
Your career is dead.
That's why this guy has got to be like
5 million tickets. Soul. Thank you.
This is because he is because
you, you made me, you like,
he's like please fucking,
you know, don't let, don't let my asshole
personality come out. Cause if it does,
I'm screwed. Like if I'm going to
fucking Douche bag, it's out. It's over.
So I think he's really making
a plate to these fools.
Have you seen that? There's
a video of him. I found, um,
I think it was on Twitter where
he's like 5 million tickets sold.
It's all because of you guys. You
did this. Thank you so much. Um,
let's lie. You do videos. Why
aren't you thinking you're fan?
You should count the tickets
and then thank him profusely.
It every you guys did well, I
already told him like, you know,
I know that they love all the whole show.
Every aspect is so exciting.
I wish you would start
bringing your manager on your
social media and your eight
and as my agent, he books all this stuff.
Agent genes is coming over. That's right.
He is. Maybe I'll do a video
with him. That's right. Yeah.
Well he's my agent to now know. So we
got to thank him so much. So I got,
I got an email, somebody wrote
in, they said, what the fuck?
Why do you keep saying amaze and excite
instead of amazing and exciting and I
guess you know,
this is probably a newer listener
realize that Kim and Kim Man,
yeah,
she is the reason that we do that.
And and uh,
in,
in this old video we played
were interviewed her,
she spoke like that.
What is amazing is amazing and
she has a very bizarre cadence.
Someone's sending a new video,
what is may her and I had gentlemen
wait long hod how'd you say Goc yeah,
it says she does, right? Yeah. So do you
want to hear it? I can't play video. Mom,
do you want to hear, I'm curious to see
what she's up to. How is our grandma,
she was on 60 minutes.
60 plus it's 60 press. No, it's not.
No,
it's not 60 press meal.
Sweet little grandma and command.
No. You can see it on
your monitor. The shot.
I'll try to help. I'll help
for this year. Yeah, go ahead.
A car hit that spot.
I like to share with you six.
Why did she say it like that?
I like to share with you ancient sex.
Is it sex secrets? Frank invited together.
See what this guy is doing to her.
That with the hand behind
the head. Yes, yes, yes, yes,
yes. I'll tell you what. For
Canine, we make fun of her.
This bitch, his body is better
than a lot of 20 year old girls.
I see now he's in shape.
She looks amazing and she's like,
she's getting fucked by a Willdabeast
right now and she's taking it,
take it and she's a real strong
performer. Let's talk performa. Yeah,
baby. Always fun. Hot.
Fuck hard.
Aren't we
six?
She said, I don't want
you to ejaculate. Oh Gee.
She's telling him to keep it in.
Okay, sure. That's a thing. I guess
don't stop.
Come
music is so specific.
I guess they have like one guy.
Yeah. One guy who does all the music.
Yeah. I don't think that
they know that for our show.
We prefer them to do it without the music.
Can you guys Redo this trailer?
I'm glad to see that man's working
again. I didn't know she stopped. Yeah,
we just haven't seen her work lately,
but I'm really excited about that.
It is exciting. It is exciting. It
is amaze. Yeah. This guy was like,
what the fuck is that? Why do you say
it like that? We don't say it that way.
It's not our fault. It's
[inaudible] fault. Yeah.
And what we do it aren't
we? Um, I have a dad boner.
Oh yes. Crossing a bridge.
That's all I know about this.
I haven't seen him so excited. I love
these so much. Right. Here we go.
I'm going over the new bridge. Whoa.
Waiting for this for over three years.
Oh really? Oh, super excited.
Not the sound so sweet. I
know. It's drive over a bridge.
Did this guys stoked about a bridge?
Three years. That's a long time. Yeah.
Scheduling rubber. Why? Here we go.
Here we go.
Okay.
Darko.
Oh my God.
Wow.
Okay.
Oh yeah. I was going to be
doing a dream now. Oh yeah.
Seems like it might be mocking
someone who does this. No,
that sounded real
legitimate. God, maybe he
did you do it again? I don't even think
about what to do it again. Not Sweet.
Awesome.
Oh yeah.
Oh, I mean this is obviously the guys
doesn't have a lot going on in his life.
Is that the only factor?
But that's a real dad word is sweet.
That's like jam.
I don't think I'll ever get this excited
about, uh, driving over a bridge.
Now they're seeing a fucking solstice
or whatever. You know what I mean?
These guys are out of their
minds. You mean, uh, a solar
eclipse, whatever it was.
Yeah.
I mean he must be a bridge and Susie
asked much like the train enthusiast,
that guy was really out of his mind.
I go super stoked about that. Yeah.
I posted a video. Right. I could like
the train. Yeah, I know the foamer. Yeah.
And Bunch of people were like,
well where'd you find this?
One guy was like, am I crazy? Is this
guy actually sound like you? You know,
cause I did it through my voice.
A little bit of screen.
Can't believe that people didn't know.
Oh yeah,
maybe this guy has been like involved in
the building of the bridge or something.
I don't know.
Maybe maybe just been watching it for
three years being constructed and,
but I mean would you would be
that excited to drive on it?
You saw that being constructed.
I Dunno. Wearing Canada,
come on. I don't know where
in Canada this guy lives.
Maybe it's a real remote part
that's for a bridge driving on a bridge.
That's a lot of rural parts of Canada,
you know.
Well obviously the,
the Dad Boehner level of excite is off
the charts there and dad boners being
excited as something that we really
have been excited about here.
So we had blow blue band throw
together blow band. That could be,
it could be his born name below band
threw together a super cut of dad.
Boners excited. I'm excited
about this. Here we go.
Yes.
Oh
God.
Along
here.
Oh my God. No. Stuck at the prominences.
That's a three.
You gotta be kidding me.
Let's blast myself.
We came up here.
We've been slipping along.
Huge battle.
That was outstanding. Thank you. That
was amazing. God, I was so good. I guess.
You know, it does feel good to take
here. Dad. Boners get that excited.
It does, right? I mean it's nice. It
lifts your spirits, lifted my spirit.
You know what I think it is?
It is childlike enthusiasm.
And the thing that's rare about that
is that you're seeing it in adult.
Most adults don't ever have that low.
And that's the nice part about the charm
of our show is we celebrate all things
childlike. The burping, we also
market, but we also celebrate it.
Yes, yes, we, we mocked the
burping. Well, we mocked the,
the excitement and one that we want to
make them insecure and never do it again.
But we also are taking a
moment to say it's nice.
We also want to strip them of their joy.
I genuinely get a thrill from Dad Boehner,
study by the pussy,
a period stuff. Then you say
something about that before the show.
Yeah.
So I was
telling you the other day
about these period panties,
you can buy that you don't have to wear
a Tampon or a pad and you just put on
these panties and they absorb all the
blood, like you free ball on your period.
How do you feel about that? Well, I
think, I feel like it's a fucking nasty.
It sounds NASA was shit, throw away your
underwear, you know, it's when I'm away.
So I guess the premise is these
panties can absorb all the blood. Yeah.
Like two tampons worth. And then you
just wash the panties. But they're like,
do you just throw the panties and
you're washing and your washer is not,
and that's what I'm asking. Nasty.
Like, you know what else you could do?
You could wear nothing.
No.
Hi.
So why don't you explain what we're
seeing? I don't want no, it's a lady doing
ah,
on her period. Nothing. No.
She's wearing white wearing
white white yoga pants.
And her period is just floating out
really good at Yoga. Really fit.
Yeah.
So she's just letting her,
her blood. Yeah. Go everywhere
on the white pants. Yeah.
Well her whole thing is like,
why should I feel bad about that?
You shouldn't feel bad, but you should.
It's just a hygiene. I think it's a,
it's unhygienic to just,
Oh,
oh
yeah, yeah. Mm hmm.
I think it kind of ruined the
mood in here for a moment.
Yeah, definitely. Made
me uncomfortable. Well,
the thing is, it is, it is natural.
Yeah. And it shouldn't be ashamed of it.
It's a whatever. Yeah. But
I do think you should, uh,
try to be hygienic about it.
That's just,
probably doesn't feel very good either
to just have your blood kind of,
you just sitting in your blood, you
know? Sure. That doesn't feel good.
But that's my concern with these
panties is like, do it anyways.
I ordered a pair today,
just so you know,
I'm gonna give it a whirl
and I will let you know.
I'll report back to everybody on these
panties. I just don't see how it can feel.
Okay. To sit in your own blood. They
swear it. They swear that you can,
you can do it. She did it. She did
it. She did it for like a feminist,
you know? Right. To make a point. Yes.
Yeah. There shouldn't be no shame. Right.
Which I don't think there should be.
No,
it's just blood coming out
of your blessing. Plus he's
bleeding right now. Ducks.
Um, Cheryl sage, excuse me,
sage. I rock. I see the
blood come in and say, right,
what?
Oh sorry.
I would say that to you. Yeah, but you
have seen everything come out of my pussy.
That's true. But I would tell you if
you were laying around and I saw that,
I'd be like,
do you know your pussies?
I'd want somebody to tell me you don't
want to bleed out on everybody's stuff.
You know? Um, I remember I never
forget this one. I gave birth to Ellis.
My favorite moment is I was like, hey
babe, what it looked like and you go,
well the head,
I saw the head and then Ellis came out
and then like a bunch of shit came out
after.
That's true.
But that's how he said it and then like
a bunch of shit and I'm just like, what?
All kinds of fluid and stuff
came in. It was fine. Right.
You don't care. I know you
don't care. I don't care either.
I just think it's funny that
you called it a bunch of shit.
I don't know who else to call it.
It looked like somebody just opened like
a sewage line, just emptied out a hotel.
I wish you would go to like a lamaze
class and lecture to all the man.
Shit's going to come out of her post,
but don't be weirded out by it.
But it's okay because the baby comes to
and then baby yours and you can do what
you want. He can marry your
mom. You remember we, uh,
maybe later when he turns 18, Waa,
remember when we played the, this lady,
she's on Lincolnton Lincoln dead.
Yeah.
This is Sharice off Morgan.
And I want to make a video to all these
guys that set up a linkedin profile just
to look at my linkedin because
they have no followers or I dunno,
they're just use linkedin
to spy on people.
Sometimes I will accept,
um,
request on linkedin because it seems
like maybe a good business connection for
my work, my writing, my books.
And then every once in a while some guy
at Luther guy will come along and think
that he can ask me out.
Linked in is not a dating APP.
Your losers stuff per queue.
Don't use linkedin to connect with
him and then asked me to travel.
Do you for date at this guy that said he
was going to be in palm springs and may
wanted to know if I wanted to come up
there and meet him for some hikes and
stuff. He was being nice, but a woman
does not travel to a man on a date,
so fuck you.
That's right. That's what's up. She's
right about that. Maybe John, maybe.
I wonder what made him think to ask you,
what date is it be that maybe
one of your videos is low?
I have come all over my face.
Maybe that's the one, but again,
it's evidence that
Linkedin is not helpful.
Linkedin is not helpful unless you're,
you know
someone, someone else. Lincoln.
Dan is not for everybody.
Fuck Lincoln.
Fugly tickling like that one.
Why I don't like him.
I don't like what he does that I like him,
but I don't like when he does that.
Gross.
What is your problem with
him and the Vegan Vagina guy?
It just, it's too creeps.
It seems like you're all worked up.
I'm not
the 34 rectifier,
which in my opinion,
possibly the best rectifier over
put into a early a guitar amplifier.
And I'm going to explain why a first off
the filament current through the heater
filament is only 1.9 amps.
That's for an ampere rex.
I assume that's the way it
is for all of them. Um, I
didn't that cleanse the palate
of the thing you didn't like,
don't you feel recently
actually erased my memory. Yeah.
I just got focused on how fucking bored I
worry this was, yeah, that's neat. Yeah.
Hmm. Well, people can't do that
and I just did that for you.
Can I tell you what I like about you?
Yeah.
This morning I learned how
to make for Tatas. Yeah.
And I this a second time I made you
for Tata this morning and you get,
you are so into it. You liked it so
much that you lost your ability to hear.
Yeah, I do that. Yeah.
And a little jeans and I were talking
and laughing and we're like, right dad.
And you were just like, if I like it,
yeah. To now like what I'm eating,
I tune out. Yeah. If I'm reading,
forget it. Oh, I know that one. Yeah.
I can't hear a thing. Yeah.
If I read something, it's
over. If I eat and it's good.
It was a really good, you won't even hear
that's true too. But what's going on?
Focus level of focus.
Right.
I'm so focused on the thing that
I'm doing are enjoying that.
I don't hear anything else.
Yeah. You like that time,
like a million years ago at my house,
you were frying bacon.
I'm going to cut in and
talk to you because you were
too busy frying your bacon.
That's why you use that expression.
No frying Bacon and Bacon.
But I didn't know it was. I didn't, yeah,
I didn't know that it applied to eating.
Yeah. Oh yeah. Definitely
applies to eating. So,
but this means that the last
12 years have shared meals.
You've likely not been listening to me
talk at all. No. Only as part of the time.
Right? Part of the time. Okay.
Because how often is the food that good
like that for Todd? It was so good. Yeah.
That I always distracted, but you can
hear me if the food's like okay. Right.
Okay. The worst the food, the more
I'm listening. Exactly. Yeah. Huh.
We to go to like Shakey's
for dinner then shaky knees.
You know I'm this hairdresser
that works with Allen.
It was his 40th birthday when I was there
and he had it at Shakey's the one in
Hollywood because apparently they'll put
your name up on the Shakey's billboard.
Who looks over at me or him.
Who are who?
Alan Guy that turned 40 oh the
guy that turned 40 it looks older.
Yeah. Wow. Well I, I, I
asked you that question.
I asked you that in an
a text the other day,
cause you looked 40 when you were 30
so do people think that you look 50 now
that you're almost 40 yes,
I get into the forties for sure.
Yeah. It's really nice. How
old do people think you are?
I mean the most extreme that I've
heard is like 45 bullshit. Yeah. Dude,
you don't look 45 but I think
people see the gray in the beard.
I'm telling you that the,
the beard being gray ages you about she
shaved her Sheila closer look closer.
No. Will you buy a box of Nice
and easy not going to do it? No.
Like my stepfather would do is just
trim the Beardmore which I'm doing on
Wednesday. It's too, it's
too thick. Alan will fix now.
I told you my step father used to buy the,
the jet black nice and easy and then he
would do his beard and the eyebrows and
the hair and he was
about 50 like jet black,
Indian and he was an Indian guy. Sure. I
look really good. How good does it look?
You can't go jet black, but
I think you should try. Yeah.
Will you try jet black?
I will not try Jaguar.
I wouldn't even make this totally.
If I would just ask him to,
you know, sprinkle in color. I wouldn't
even do, not that I'm doing it.
If I were doing it, I would do
a modest version. I like it.
I like your silver whiskers.
I just love them.
I like your silver bear look so verbatim.
You know what else he
did with the Frittata,
which really made me realize
what a savage you are,
is that you like a bear.
They've ever seen bears eating a honey
hive and there's all the bees swarming
around the hive a bear.
Well,
disregard the bees and keep chomping
on the hive and let the bee sting his
mouth. That's something I've done a
long time. If it tastes good, it's hot.
Keep eating because it tastes
good. Ear through burns. Yeah.
You pushed past the hot,
the heat of the Frittata because it was,
it was fresh out of the oven.
Piping hot. I had the, Oh yeah, I had
to wait a good 10 minutes. But not you.
You pushed past the burns.
The third degree burns on your mouth.
They're appealing right now. Yeah.
I have a skin peels right now.
I've done that so many times.
So
you just let the bee sting
you let them stay. Yeah. Um,
all right. Genes. We should
wrap it up. All right, gene. Um,
I have a great, thank you so much for
listening. Without you news like you got
you, got you, you, you, you,
you, you, you, you, you,
you, you, you, you, you, you,
you download it. You streamed
it. You've watched it.
You watching this on youtube right now.
This is because of you.
The studio was all you
so proud of you guys.
Love TNC. You post is bleed. No.
A totality by DJ boy butter.
Do you say boy butter did one
of our great songs recently? Um,
I think he did just like the case. I
think the gays. So this is his new song.
Totality. That's it. Thank you
for listening. Watching the show.
Your mom's house,
podcast.com Tom segura.com
thousand ranch.com and uh,
my sheep purples.
I'm hoping
to have a bonus episode up
for you in a few days. Uh,
one of the live shows from Irvine.
Alright,
bye Jean.
Do you want to see the biggest
dad bought her a favor? Yeah,
this big huge meadow
Cologne called the hill.
It's glass glass, glass, glass of
cool stuff to slick stuff.
Neat stuff.
Just slap it along.
Something along here.
What's glass glass?
Glass glass.
Bad, bad, bad, bad light,
light, light, light, light, light,
light, blue, denim, privately, white,
better high up, round, braided belts,
and then Sandy, my jeans. Yeah.